สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะน้องเกรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันพุธค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 1
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมีนาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
ปีค.ศอะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วัน
อังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 28
วันที่ 1
กุมภาพันธ์
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
ปีค.ศอะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันพฤหัสบดีวัน
ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 2 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมีนาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
ค่ะตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา
เที่ยงคืน
กี่นาที
เที่ยงคืน 53 นาทีค่ะ
เที่ยงคืน 53 นาทีอีกนิดนึงก็จะตี 1 แล้ว
เสร็จประมาณ 7 นาทีก็จะตี 1 ตอนนี้ก็เป็น
เวลากลางคืนเราสองคนเนี่ยยังตื่นอยู่อีก
หรอคะ
ไม่นอนหรอ
ไม่นอนค่ะ
เป็นผึ้งเหรอคะ
เป็นใครนะ
เป็นผึ้ง
นักเรียนครูพาคิดดูสิคะว่าตอนนี้เที่ยง
คืนแล้วอ่ะเราสองคนยังทำงานน่ะสอนภาษาไทย
สอนภาษาไทยอ่ะเราชอบทำงานมากๆก็เหมือน
ผึ้งไง
อย่างนี้ป้าผึ้งอ่ะ
นะ
ครูฟ้าวาดผึ้งดีกว่าผู้หญิงว่ารู้สึกว่า
นักเรียนอาจจะคิดว่าเอ๊ะตัวอะไรหรือเปล่า
ก็เหมือนผึ้งอยู่นะ
ชอบทำงานน่ะ
ผู้หญิง
เราสองคน
ประมาณตี 1 แล้วอ่ะเราสองคนยังทำงานยัง
สอนๆๆภาษาไทยอยู่เลยเราก็ต้องเหมือนผึ้ง
เพราะครูฟ้าแม่มาแล้วสีเหลืองนะคะ
ใช่สมัยพึ่งเนี่ยก็จะมีอันนี้เป็นต้นไม้
ใช่ไหมต้นไม้เนี่ยก็จะมีรังผึ้ง
น้ำผึ้ง
ก็จะอยู่ที่นี่อันนี้คือบ้านใช่ไหมเหมือน
บ้านของผึ้งก็คือรังผึ้งผึ้งก็จะออกไปทำ
งาน
ชอบทำงานก็เลยคิดว่าเหมือนเราสองคนไง
ใช่ค่ะเราสองคนเนี่ยนะคะก็ชอบทำงานนะคะทำ
ให้เราเนี่ย
ไม่หลับไม่นอนใช่ไหม
ใช่เหมือนพึ่งแต่ว่าก็ไม่อยากเหมือนผึ้ง
อย่างนึงอ่ะค่ะครูฟ้า
อะไรอ่ะไม่อยากเหมือนทำ
เราทำงานได้แต่ว่าผึ้งเนี่ยมันอยู่บนต้น
ไม้ใช่ไหมบางครั้งเนี่ยก็จะมี
อะไรมี
อันนี้คืออะไรของหมีเนี่ย
อันนี้เป็นหมีป่ะ
ก็จะมีหมีอ่ะ
มีหมีมันจะมากินผึ้งไงหมีมันชอบกินผึ้ง
ไม่ใช่หรอ
หมีไม่ได้ยินผึ้งค่ะผู้หญิงแต่ว่าหมีตาม
เพื่อน
ในที่รังผึ้งเนี่ยก็จะมีน้ำผึ้งใช่ไหมน้ำ
ผึ้ง
น้ำผึ้ง
ได้เนาะถ้าหมีไม่ได้กินผึ้ง
แต่หมีชอบผึ้งไหมอ่ะ
ไม่รู้
ซึ่งน่าจะไม่ชอบหมีค่ะเพราะว่าหมีชอบกิน
น้ำผึ้งไง
มาแย่งน้ำผึ้งของผึ้ง
วันนี้ครูฟ้าจะเล่านิทานเกี่ยวกับน้ำผึ้ง
เกี่ยวกับหมีหรือเกี่ยวกับผึ้งคะเกี่ยว
กับผึ้งนี่แหละ
พอจะเล่านิทานชื่อว่าหมีกับผึ้งอันนี้
ผึ้งใช่ไหม
ไม่มีนะคะ
แล้วก็
จมูก
เป็นสามเหลี่ยมนะคะแล้วก็ป่าแล้วก็เคี่ยว
ด้วย
มีค่ะมีน่ากลัวนะคะได้ตาหมี่นะคะ
แล้วหมีก็มีหน้ากลมๆไหมหน้าหมีเนี่ย
กลมใช่ไหม
แล้วก็คอ
คอ
แล้วหมีก็มีมือ
สีเหรอ
[เพลง]
วันนี้
ฟ้าก็จะมาเล่านิทานเรื่องหมีกับผึ้ง
แล้วเป็นยังไงคะนิทานเรื่องนี้เนี่ย
กาลครั้งหนึ่งนานมาแล้ว
ค่ะ
มีอะไรคะ
มีหมีนะคะ
ตัวหนึ่ง
ค่ะ
หมีเนี่ยก็มีบ้านอยู่ในป่าใช่มั้ยนัก
เรียน
ตายหมีมันอยู่ในป่าไง
ป่าก็เหมือนบ้านของหมี
เพราะหมีกินนอนอาบน้ำแปรงฟันเนี่ยหาอาหาร
ก็ในป่าใช่ไหมคะ
หมีเลยอยู่ในป่านะคะแล้วก็ใช้ชีวิตอยู่ใน
ป่า
ค่ะ
แล้วก็ใหญ่ก็ปกติไหมหมีอยู่ในป่า
วันนึงเนี่ยหมีก็เดินเล่นค่ะผู้หญิง
เดินๆ
ต้นไม้สวยฮัลโหล
เดินเล่นดูต้นไม้ดูดอกไม้ในป่าเหรอคะครู
ฟ้าเพราะว่าหมีเนี่ยไม่มี iPhone นะคะนัก
เรียน
เล่นโซเชียลไม่ได้เล่น Facebook ไม่ได้
หมีก็เลยเดินเล่น
อยู่ในป่า
หาอะไรกินอยู่ในป่าแล้ววันนึงเนี่ยก็หมี
เนี่ยก็เดินมาเจอ
ต้นไม้ใช่ไหม
เจออะไรเจออะไรบนต้นไม้เจออะไรที่ต้นไม้
เจอต้นไม้พูดได้หรอ
ต้นไม้พูดไม่ได้นะคะผู้หญิงแต่หมีน่ะเจอ
อะไรคะ
มันคืออะไรอ่ะอะไรกลมๆ
อะไรอ่ะคะครูฟ้า
ผู้หญิงรู้ไหมคืออะไร
ผู้หญิงไม่รู้เลยค่ะครูฟ้าหมีมาเจออะไร
เนี่ยที่ครูฟ้ากำลังวาดอยู่เนี่ยนะคะอัน
นี้เนี่ยคืออะไรคะครูฟ้า
แพนเค้กหรือเปล่า
อันนี้เนี่ยนะคะเขาเรียกว่า
รังผึ้ง
อ๋อหมีก็เดินเล่นแล้วก็มาเจอ
มาเจอรังผึ้งหรอคะครูฟ้าใช่ค่ะ
รังผึ้งเนี่ยก็ต้องมีผึ้งใช่ไหมคะนัก
เรียนใช่อันนี้หรือเปล่าคะครูฟ้าที่ครู
ฟ้าวาดเนี่ยเล็กๆที่บินอยู่บินๆๆอยู่รอบๆ
รังผึ้งก็คือผึ้ง
ถูกต้องแล้วหมี
เดินมาเจอผึ้งใช่ไหมแล้วก็รังผึ้งซึ่งพอ
มาถึงเนี่ย
มันก็ได้กลิ่น
หมีได้กลิ่นหรอคะ
หมีมีจมูกหรอ
คุณฟ้าบอกแล้วนี่อะไร
เพราะครูหญิงอันนี้คืออะไร
กลิ่นหอมหรือว่า
เหม็นคะ
หอมค่ะ
[เพลง]
งั้นแปลว่าครูฟ้าบอกว่ารังผึ้งแหละมีผึ้ง
ก็ไม่ได้มีผึ้งอย่างเดียวสิคะรังผึ้งก็
ต้องมีน้ำผึ้งด้วย
นะคะ
น้ำผึ้งน้ำผึ้ง
แต่น้ำผึ้งเนี่ย
หอมจริงๆนะครูฟ้า
ใช่ค่ะน้ำผึ้งเนี่ยหอมมากและหมีก็ชอบกิน
น้ำผึ้งใช่ไหม
พ่อหมีเนี่ยได้กลิ่นหอมของน้ำผึ้งหมีคิด
จะทำอะไรไหมคะ
หมีก็เดินเข้าไปเลยค่ะเดินๆเดินเดินเดิน
ไปถึงเนี่ยก็ใช้มือ
ทำอะไร
ดึงรังผึ้งมา
ค่ะ
เพราะอยากจะกินน้ำผึ้ง
ใช่
ป่ะ
แล้ว
หมีเนี่ยนะคะก็เลย
ดึงรังผึ้งลงมาแล้วก็กิน
กินถ้วยทั้งลังเลยหรอคะกินรังแต่รังผึ้ง
มันก็กินได้นะ
และหมีก็กินค่ะเข้าไปทั้งหมดเลย
ซึ่ง
รังผึ้งเนี่ยก็จะมีผึ้งใช่ไหม
ใช่เพราะว่ารังผึ้งก็เหมือนก็คือบ้านของ
ผึ้งไงแล้วหมีกินบ้านของผึ้งผึ้งอยู่ใน
บ้าน
ผึ้งเนี่ยก็โกรธค่ะผู้หญิง
เป็นผู้หญิงผู้หญิงก็โกรธค่ะครูฟ้าเพิ่ง
ทำยังไง
พอโกรธเนี่ย
ผึ้งก็บินมาแล้วก็
ต่อย
หรอนักเรียน
ไม่ใช่นะคะผึ้งเนี่ยใช้ตรงนี้
แหลมๆเนี่ยหรอ
ใช่แหลมๆ
เราเรียกอะไรครูฟ้าอ่ะ
เขาเรียกว่าอะไรอ่ะเหล็กใน
ตรงนี้แหลมๆเนี่ยเป็นเหล็กในใช้แหลมๆตรง
นี้ใช้เหล็กในเนี่ยต่อยหมีเหรอคะ
ใช่อ่ะผึ้งก็ใช้เหล็กใน
ต่อยหมี
1 ตัวหรอ
ผึ้ง 1 ตัวหรือเปล่าคะครูฟ้าทั้งหมดเลย
ค่ะ
ไม่รู้กี่ตัวนะอาจจะ
มากกว่า 50 ตัวไหม
มากกว่า 50 ตัวอยู่แล้วนะคะผึ้งก็ใช้
เหล็กในเนี่ยรุมๆๆต่อยหมี
ค่ะแต่
เหล็กในเนี่ยมันไม่โดนหมีเพราะว่าอะไร
เพราะว่าหมีเนี่ย
มันมีขนใช่ไหม
ถ้าเราเป็นคนเนี่ยนิดเนื้อใช่ไหมผึ้งก็
ใช้เหล็กในแล้วก็ต่อยได้เลยแต่ว่าหมี
เนี่ยมันมีขนขนก็ไม่โดนตัวหมีเหรอคะเหล็ก
ในของผึ้งอ่ะใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าขนของหมีเนี่ย
นะคะหมีก็ขนหนาอยู่นะ
เนี่ยไม่โดนหมีเลยค่ะ
งั้นหมีก็ไม่เป็นอะไรเลยไม่เจ็บไม่ปวด
โอเคสบายๆ
สบายๆซึ่งในก็คิด
ทำยังไงดีใช้เหล็กในต่อยหมีไม่ได้
หมีขนเยอะใช่ไหมหมีเนี่ยขนหนา
ทำยังไงดี
ทำยังไงอ่ะ
ผึ้งก็เลยคุยกัน
เพิ่งหนึ่งเพิ่งสองเพิ่งสามเพิ่งสี่เพิ่ง
ห้านะคะ
ใช่แล้วเพิ่งก็เลยบอกว่า
ถ้าเราต่อยไปที่ตัวของหมีเนี่ยหมีเนี่ยมี
ขนนะคะต่อยไม่ได้
เพราะฉะนั้นเราก็ต้องต่อยไปที่หน้าของหมี
แล้วหน้าของหมีไม่มีขนหรอ
มีนิดหน่อย
[เพลง]
ที่หน้าของหมีนะคะอืมค่ะเพราะว่าผึ้งไม่
มีบ้านแล้วไง
ผึ้งก็จะใช้
เหล็กในตรงนี้ใช่ไหม
ใช่ค่ะ
ระหว่างที่มีกำลังนั่งกิน
น้ำผึ้งอย่างอร่อยแล้วก็กินรังผึ้งด้วย
ฝูงผึ้งเลยนะคะนักเรียน
ฝูงผึ้งก็คือผึ้งใช่ไหม
คุณ
อ่า 10 ขึ้นไป
เอออาจจะ 10 ตัว 20 ตัวก็คือเพิ่งๆๆเยอะ
มากๆเนี่ยฝูงผึ้งทำอะไรคะครูฟ้า
สูงขึ้นเนี่ยนะคะก็บินมาหาหมีค่ะ
แล้วก็ใช้เหล็กในเนี่ยค่ะ
ทิ่มไปที่หน้าของหมี
ต่อยที่หน้าเกาหลีใช่หมีเนี่ยนะคะมีขนที่
หน้าแต่ว่ามีขนที่หน้านิดหน่อย
ไม่ได้หนาไม่ได้เยอะเหมือนขนที่ตัว
ทำให้หมีเนี่ยร้องด้วยความเจ็บ
โอ๊ยโอ๊ยโอ๊ยเจ็บ
แล้วทำยังไงต่อเป็นยังไงต่อคะ
หมีก็เลยวิ่งหนีไปค่ะ
ค่ะ
วิ่งหนีเข้าไปในป่า
แล้วผึ้งเนี่ยบินตามหมีไปไหม
ใช่ค่ะเพิ่งก็บินตามหมีนะคะแล้วก็วิ่ง
เข้าไปในป่าหมีวิ่งหนีซึ่งก็บินตาม
จบจบ
แล้ว
แค่นี้หรอคะ
นี่คือนิทานของครูฟ้าแล้ว
หมีมากินรังผึ้งผึ้งโกรธต่อยหมีแล้วหนีๆ
เจ็บก็วิ่งหนีแล้วเพิ่งก็บินตามไป
แล้วนิทานเรื่องนี้เนี่ยสอนอะไรเราคะครู
ฟ้าถ้าเด็กๆเด็กๆนะอาจจะ 3 ขวบถึง 7 ขวบ
เนี่ยเด็กๆฟังนิทานเรื่องนี้สอนอะไรอ่ะ
อยากกินน้ำผึ้งใช่ค่ะน้ำผึ้งไม่อร่อย
นิทานเรื่องนี้เลยนะคะบอกว่า
ถ้าเราทำไม่ดีกับคนอื่น
คนอื่นก็จะทำไม่ดีกับเรา
หรือว่าถึงแม้ว่าเราจะตัวใหญ่เราแข็งแรง
ผึ้งเนี่ยตัวเล็กๆหรือว่าเราเนี่ยอาจจะ
แข็งแรงไม่ได้แต่ถ้าเรามีมีหลายๆคนแล้วก็
คิดใช่ไหมช่วยกันคิดเราก็สู้ได้ไง
หรือเปล่า
ใช่แล้วค่ะนี่แหละ
นิทานวันนี้นะคะเราอยากคือหมีเนี่ยไปกิน
บ้านของผึ้งใช่ไหมรังผึ้งเนี่ยนะคะก็คือ
บ้าน
ของผึ้งนั่นแหละ
หมีก็ไปกิน
รังผึ้งหรืออาจจะกินผึ้งเข้าไปด้วย
ใช่เพราะว่าหมีก็ทำไม่ดีกับผึ้งหมีก็คิด
ผึ้งเนี่ยตัวเล็กๆฉันเนี่ยตัวใหญ่มากกว่า
ฉันมีขนผึ้งทำอะไรฉันไม่ได้
แต่ถ้าผึ้งเนี่ยหลายๆตัวใช่ไหมช่วยกันถึง
แม้จะตัวเล็กๆช่วยกัน
ก็หนีก็เจ็บหมีก็กลัวใช่ไหมหมีเนี่ยวิ่ง
หนีผึ้งเลย
เราทำร้ายคนอื่นนะคะเราทำไม่ดีกับคนอื่น
คนอื่นก็จะทำไม่ดีกับเราเหมือนกันอันนี้
คืออันเรื่องนี้นะคะนักเรียนใช่ค่ะเราทำ
ไม่ดีกับผึ้งผึ้งเจ็บผึ้งโดนกินผึ้งไม่มี
บ้าน
หมีก็ต้องเจ็บเหมือนผึ้งใช่ไหมคะ
หมีก็กิน
รังผึ้งกินน้ำผึ้งหมีก็ยังเอามาทั้งรังสิ
ไม่รู้เหมือนกันน่ะเออหมีประเทศไทยกินรัง
ผึ้งไหมผู้หญิงก็ไม่รู้เหมือนกันไงป้าก็
ไม่รู้เพราะครูฟ้าไม่ใช่หมีนะคะใช่ค่ะแต่
ว่าถึงแม้ว่าผึ้งจะตัวเล็กๆใช่ไหมถึงเรา
ตัวเล็กเราไม่แข็งแรงแต่ถ้าเรามีเพื่อน
เพื่อนหลายๆคนเราก็สู้คนที่ตัวใหญ่ได้
เหมือนกันคนตัวใหญ่ทำไม่ดีกับเราเราตัว
เล็ก
ถึงแล้วเราจะเป็นตัวเล็กๆตัวเดียวนะแต่
ถ้าเราคิดอ่ะเราก็สู้ได้เหมือนกันนะคะอัน
นี้ก็เป็นนิทานเรื่องหมีกับผึ้งนะคะที่
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยเอามาเล่าให้นักเรียนฟังเนาะ
ก็นักเรียนอยากเป็นหมีหรือผึ้งก็คอมเมนต์
บอกเราได้นะคะแต่ว่าตอนนี้ครูหญิงขอไปกิน
น้ำผึ้งก่อนดีกว่ามันจะเป็นหมี่แล้ว
เดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้านะคะ
สวัสดีค่ะ